en 2021 ya plus d'argent qui a été
investi dans les obligations vertes que
dans celle destinée à financer
l'industrie des énergies fossiles
c'était la première fois et certainement
pas la dernière
les choses se passent du côté de la
finance durable
la croissance la finance verte est juste
fulgurante en 2020 c'est plus de 35
milliards de dollars qui sont allés vers
des entreprises qui se disent plus
responsable de l'environnement et des
communautés ou qui se consacre à la
transition énergétique
ça représente environ 35 % des actifs
gérés dans le monde mais ça pourrait
être encore plus si le moindre petit
dehors de nos économies et si l'argent
qu'on voit tous toucher à la retraite
était placée plus consciencieusement ça
pourrait nous aider à atténuer les pires
crises environnementales et à protéger
notre épargne
[Musique]
mois les questions d'argent les
placements les scénic c'est comme
l'everest la vie d'adulte c'est gris
comme la neige sale s'est réservé une
élite qui s'affairent à quoi
d'économiser autant c'est pour mourir
dans un kit d escalade à 5000 $
on composte on recycle enfin attention
aux déplacements piano voyage moi je
fais presque tout se
[Musique]
mélange va falloir que je m'occupe de
mes finances si je veux qu'elle s'occupe
de la planète quand je pense à la
finance j'ai un petit préjugés j'imagine
des hommes en complet cravate qui brasse
des grosses affaires
c'est vrai que la moitié de la
population canadienne la moins nantis
possède à faire 10 % de tous les actifs
financiers
mais même quand on ne veut pas de
placement nos pensions de vieillesse
font rouler l'économie et elles polluent
seulement le régime des rentes du québec
le bas de laine des québécois
le minimum de retraite pollue autant
actuellement question agitait plus d'un
million de us sur une faute et c'est
encore plus élevé pour le régime de
pensions du canada
j'ai trouvé une experte en finance
durable à ses patientes pour
m'accompagner dans ma recherche elle
s'appelle rosalie van d'être
[Musique]
bon rosalie est ce que c'est normal ça
m'intéresse pas pantoute la finance moi
je pense que les questions financières
sont des questions qui sont nécessaires
à tous les citoyens ne serait-ce que si
on oublie notre argent individuelle mais
qu'on parle de l'administration des
finances publiques je pense entre autres
à la retraite ces sommes leur cd
milliards des centaines de milliards qui
sont investis au nom des canadiens et au
nom des québécois en ce moment en
actions et les sommes sont placés dans
plein d'endroits du monde au canada bien
évidemment mais aussi être dans plein
d'endroits du monde ce qui fait que
collectivement on est propriétaire de
buddh aéroports au royaume-uni en
australie deux terrains cultivables de
forêt est en fait notre argent quand
elle est mise à profit comme ça elle
sert à du développement économique et la
beauté de la finance durable c'est que
c'est une finance qui veut intégrer les
considérations environnementales
sociales et de gouvernance dans les
processus dans les produits
d'investissement de financements et on
devrait s'y intéresser parce que c'est
une finance qui a aidé à bâtir le monde
de dôme et ça c'est le fameux le sgg
d'une part tout en fouillant sur les
investissements responsables
c'est des critères que les entreprises
promettent de respecter pour obtenir du
financement des investisseurs dits
responsables
des entreprises qui font des promesses
je sais pas pour vous mais moi ça allume
une lumière e merde merde qui n'y avait
qu'un petit tour d'eure de marketing
plus joli sur la question plus je me
rends compte que le nerf de la guerre
pour que la finance soit vraiment
durable c'est d'amener les entreprises à
mesurer et à divulguer leurs impacts
environnementaux et sociaux au juste
leur performance financière
les produits les parents ont d'ores et
déjà des conversations des entreprises
pour leur dis attention ça sans vie nous
on veut avoir votre bilan carbone qu'on
veut le voir baisser et donc sur cette
ville y dialogue qui ont lieu en ce
moment depuis des années donc les
compagnies ont pas le choix d'agir parce
que le sentent les pouvoirs publics elle
le centre des consommateurs clegg
commensal entendent davantage des
actionnaires ce qui leur donne toute
légitimité dans le fond dans l'action
rosalie est ce que je peux juste choisir
des placements et sg puis dormir
tranquille parce que je publie seulement
à ce 7e en vagues c'est tellement
général j'inviterais
l'investisseur à aller un peu plus en
détails pour moi environnement ça peut
vouloir dire changement climatique ça
peut vouloir dire biodiversité ça peut
vouloir dire des questions liées à l'eau
donc juste voir l'acronyme régis et
c'est un peu comme le site un indicateur
de base pour commencer à qui donc est ce
que ce serait mieux d'investir seulement
dans des compagnies qui se consacre
uniquement à l'environnement on peut
décider d'investir dans des super
champion sur le plan environnemental
social et gouvernance plus ondimba nous
on veut choisir les meilleurs
mais c'est pas obligatoirement ça on
peut décider d'investir dans des moyens
de classe ou même à la limite des
mauvais joueurs pour dire sciemment on
veut les aider à progresser on peut les
aider nous mêmes si on évite tout petits
investisseurs jodie les moyens
d'intervenir quand on est actionnaire à
qui ça c'est vraiment intéressant le 26
mai 2021 j'ai un petit groupe
d'investisseurs qui a fait plier un
géant la pétrolière américaine exxon qui
a longtemps nié et cacher les faits de
ces produits sur le climat ils ont
commencé par acheter des actions après
ils ont convaincu les autres
actionnaires qu'exxon devait améliorer
son bilan climatique pour améliorer sa
situation financière
et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont réussi à
remplacer trois membres du cio par des
personnes qui vont faire pression sur la
multinationale pour qu'il réduise son
empreinte sur l'environnement
mais les actionnaires d'exxon sont pas
devenus écologistes jour au lendemain ce
qui fait bouger les investisseurs en ce
moment ce sont les risques énormes que
la crise environnementale fait peser sur
les entreprises
s'il ya autant de monde qui se lancent
en finance durable en ce moment c'est en
grande partie parce qu'elle sert à
protéger les capitaux des risques
environnementaux
[Musique]
ce qui change aussi la donne c'est que
les énergies renouvelables cote moins
cher à produire qu'avant et que c'est
plus vrai qu'un investissement va est un
investissement qui est moins rentable
les rendements sont comparables dans la
plupart des études on commence à avoir
même des études récentes qui démontre
que les produits et j'ai sont moins
risquées ça veut dire que quand la
bourse chute les compagnies qui démonte
des très bonnes performances
environnementales sociales gouvernance
vont peut-être chuté moins longtemps ou
chuter de manière moins drastiques
donc c'est la conception de l'entreprise
qui est en train de changer on peut pas
considérer le risque et le rendement
financier sans considérer les
répercussions sur l'environnement et
social
[Musique]
bon j'ai un peu plus envie de mieux
investir mon argent mais les fonds
placements responsables qui en a 250 qui
sont offerts au canada je pourrais lire
tous les détails de ces fonds le
l'information et l'exil elle est
accessible c'est la loi mais je pourrais
aussi prendre tout ce temps là pour
terminer ma maîtrise en collage et m'en
remettre à quelqu'un qui s'y connaît
beaucoup mieux que moi
pour ali moi quand j'entends par les ans
à votre conseiller financier c'est comme
si on faisait prend rendez vous avec ton
grossistes moi je trouve ça ressemble
peut-être plus aux médecins que le
dentiste loger parle de la recherche de
darwish je parle du médecin comme la
personne à qui on va devoir parler de
choses quand même souffert ses intimes
il faut un peu s'ouvrir si on veut
recevoir les bons conseils on peut se
permettre de poser des questions cette
personne pour voir qu'est ce qu'elle
pense de la finance durable de
l'investissement responsable
est ce que la personne a des produits
est ce que la personne s'est dotée d'une
formation d'une certification reconnue
dans le domaine parce qu'il en existe au
canada je pense que j'aurais pas le
choix d'un magazine une personne qui
évolue dans le domaine depuis longtemps
si je vais être bien conseillé surtout
au fil de mes recherches j'ai lu pour un
article qui évoque des ont vraiment
sombre la finance durable pour le moment
les bénéfices environnementaux sont pas
vraiment là peut-être qu'ils sont
difficiles à mesurer que c'est juste une
question de temps avant que les effets
positifs se fassent sentir
mais il ya aussi des joueurs qui sont là
seulement pour profiter de l'engouement
pour la finance durable parce qu'il ya
pas de réglementation stricte en matière
d'éco responsabilité ni d'encadrement
des critères esg en amérique du nord on
va se le dire pour l'instant et encore
beaucoup de place pour les couples en
chemin
[Musique]
ce qui va arriver dans les prochaines
années on va mettre encore plus de
ressources en commun pour créer des
labels des mécanismes d'identification
des catégorisations des études qui vont
offrir plus d'informations monsieur
madame tout le monde à l'investisseur
on le sait qu'il ya des projets de
réglementation aussi qu'ils vont voir le
jour qui vont permettre de clarifier
parce qu'on voit que les européens le
fonds
on voit quand d'autres régions du monde
ils ont recours à ces outils là donc
c'est juste une question de temps avant
que ça rejoint l'amérique du nord mais
une question de temps ça va être
fonction aussi de l'intensité avec
laquelle les gens posent la question
puis le monde sait ce qui nous attend
dans les prochains mois dans les
prochaines années
il ya une partie de moi qui veux
vraiment croire que la finance est un
puissant levier pour vous aider à
freiner les dégâts environnementaux
mais investir s'impliquent de s'informer
sur la question surtout si on veut
rester critique pour ça on vous a
préparé un petit guide sur le site de
carbone où vous allez trouver plaignants
qui ont des mines d'or d'informations
dont un palmarès des institutions
financières qui financent le plus
l'industrie fossile peut-être que votre
banque en fait partie à ce sujet le il
ya plusieurs spécialistes qui pensent
que des investissements les énergies
fossiles ne se serait pas la meilleure
solution je sais c'est contre intuitif
tellement qu'on ne distingue dit
consacrer notre prochain reportage ya
produit que je repasse cas demande pour
ces services là la baisse de prix de ses
actions ne s'est pas matérielle décide
donc on ne voit pas une chute du prix de
ces titres là parce que au moment des
investissements